the Hulk is one of Marvel's most popular
characters so it's no surprise that the
company turned to the big green guy when
it came time to launch the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in 2008 Hulk laid low
for four years after his debut and was
the breakout hit of the Avengers so why
haven't we seen more of the big green
guy here are a few reasons why Marvel
won't give Hulk another movie a history
of flops because the Hulk is such an
iconic character the pressure was on in
2003 for angley's Hulk film which
starred Eric Bana as Bruce Banner the
movie wasn't terrible but it wasn't
great either
earning lukewarm ratings across the
board and it definitely wasn't good
enough to warrant a sequel fast forward
five years and the fledgling Marvel
Studios was looking to take advantage of
two of the major characters still under
their control to anchor new film
franchises Iron Man and the Hulk Iron
Man hit first and thanks to the charisma
of Robert Downey jr. it hit big The
Incredible Hulk was the second film on
the slate debuting a few months after
Iron Man and it was not as good the film
received decent reviews and was a so-so
performer at the box office but compared
to the coolness and profitability of
Iron Man Hulk just didn't hold up when
it came time to choose which character
to be sued Hulk
God's most
complete sleep asleep a canceled sequel
Marvel was already planning another Hulk
filmed pretty early on but with the
popularity of Marvel's other characters
the project was shelved Edward Norton
was eventually axed and recast with Mark
Ruffalo in the Avengers in a 2008
interview with GamesRadar Edmund spilled
the beans on why the Incredible Hulk
felt unfinished saying we left a lot out
on purpose it's definitely intended as a
chapter one my attitude was let's start
with a mystery and slowly unpeel what
the roots of it are all the way through
like let's have revelations even in the
third act about what set this whole
thing in motion unfortunately those
plans never materialized for Norton but
a similar strategy has been planned for
Mark Ruffalo's Hulk Ruffalo told Yahoo
movies that Hulk will be getting his Jew
over the next few years saying we've
worked a really interesting arc into
Thor 3 Avengers 3 and 4 for banner that
I think will when it's all added up will
feel like a Hulk movie of standalone
movie a full schedule between sequels
and originals Marvel Studios has cranked
out a mind-boggling 14 movies over the
last eight years but they're still just
getting started they already have at
least six movies currently shooting or
at some stage in production including
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 Black
Panther and Thor Ragnarok
even if Marvel wanted to make a new Hulk
film it would be at least four years
before they could even fit it in the
schedule considering just about every
Marvel movie is a hit and they have to
keep the fun train rolling by
introducing new characters it's hard to
make space for a guy who already had two
shots at solo glory Hulk isn't cheap
making a movie where the main character
can turn into a giant green rage monster
isn't easy and neither is finding a way
to fit all that effects work into the
budget
sure you can keep him in Bruce Banner
mode for a lot of the time
then viewers will just buy that time
waiting Froome to Hulk out if the budget
differences aren't obvious mm eights The
Incredible Hulk costs 10 million dollars
more to make than Iron Man and Hulk
didn't even need to have any fancy armor
fabricated The Avengers
earned an Academy Award nomination in
the visual effects category so the
expectations to make a Hulk that doesn't
look like a ticked-off Shrek as one
reviewer called angley's Hulk a very
high and very costly
Hulk is better on a team though the Hulk
left the Avengers after his first
adventure with them in the comics he
just works better when he's surrounded
by other characters that's not to say
that the story of Bruce Banner isn't
compelling but we've already had two
attempts to dig into it with minimal
success there's also the fact that Hulk
is basically a force of nature and it's
hard to give him a bad guy that he can't
just smash into bits or rip in half but
in The Avengers films ultra powerful bad
guys a standard so the heroic Hulk can
still seem like an underdog when the
battle royale kicks off Hulk's in a
struggle The Hulk is a great character
but when you translate him from page to
screen it's not easy to tell a
compelling Hulk story why his biggest
struggle is within himself and that's
not an easy thing to showcase in a
medium that typically relies on
explosions instead of thought bubbles
some of the best Hulk stories are
character studies and that doesn't
usually fit into a successful superhero
film we can't have sad walking away
piano music all of the time but it's a
huge part of the character distribution
rights in addition to all the reasons
we've already listed there's also been a
lot of confusion surrounding the film
rights to a Hulk sequel according to a
Collider interview with Mark Ruffalo
Marvel doesn't really have the rights to
that yet that's still universe's
property so there's that issue that's a
big impediment to moving forward with
that Ruffalo was kind of right but the
situation is a little
more complicated Universal apparently
does have the right of its first refusal
to distribute a new Hulk film which
could create some problems but it's not
a big enough roadblock to keep Marvel
from making the movie they famously cut
a deal with Sony to share spider-man and
the process is still pretty complicated
but certainly far from impossible Hulk
gets weird
Hulk dates back to the 1960s during the
glory days of Stan Lee and Jack Kirby if
you've ever read any of the Hulk's early
appearances you know it can get a little
strange which makes a truly authentic
Hulk a little harder to pull off on the
big screen
Captain America fighting Nazis is a
relatable selling point for a film but
Hulk dressed as a clown juggling
elephants or being assaulted in a YMCA
shower might end up being a bit more
complicated for the multiplex even later
stories like the fan-favorite
world war hulk which is reportedly being
incorporated to some extent into thor
ragnarok and the time hopping
indestructible Hulk agent of shield
could be a big ask of typical mainstream
audiences honestly though this was weird
enough
[Music]
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the ones you just saw and leave us
a comment to let us know why you think
Hulk can't get his own movie
[Music]